Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
June 16th,
2014 how the hell are your,
how are you doing?
Yeah,
no.
Are you enjoying the fucking Saba?
When does this summer start officially?
I know it's June 20 something.
I'll tell you a book deal.
That global warming,
it's kind of hard to tell.
Um,
I got to watch the volume this week.
Okay.
I have to keep it low.
Fucking key because uh,
I am actually recording.
Um,
Sunday,
June 15th.
I'm in Salt Lake City.
Okay,
I'll go.
I didn't pronounce it.
Salt Lake City.
We had a hotel room here and I got to keep my,
uh,
my voice down cause I don't want to offend,
you know,
whatever Mormon is next door and the whole,
that hotel room,
right?
What's his fucking 22 wives or whatever the hell they do.
You know,
you don't,
it's funny when you come out here to Utah,
you think what you're gonna see is you're going to see a bunch of Mormons,
right?
Walking around dressed like the runs little house in the prairie.
And,
you know,
one guy with like,
four wives,
five wives,
and uh,
I don't know how many times I've been out to Utah,
but it finally dawned on me that if you have five wives,
okay,
and you know,
each one of them wants to have like two kids.
The average woman wants a couple of kids,
right?
I'd like a boy and a girl,
you know,
one of each,
looking at you like you possess that sort of like trick shots,
sperm that go quite like,
are you playing a game of horse?
All right,
you got to make the shot from over here and over here.
One of each.
Then you move onto the next round.
So that right there with,
you have five wives,
one of each,
right?
If you're going to have kids and wants a boy and a girl,
you're looking at 10 kids,
you're going to have 10 kids,
five wives.
I mean,
how many bedroom house are you going to have to buy?
Basically what I'm saying is,
the reason why I've never run into one of these people with all the wives is
there's no way they can afford to live in the city.
You know,
you'd have to,
you'd have to rent out a whole floor of a fucking condom,
a skyscraper there,
condominium a Co op if you will.
So that's what it is.
That's where they are,
man.
They're,
they're all,
they're all over the fucking hill there,
over the hill.
So I guess I'm never going to find them.
So you're probably saying,
well,
Bill,
what do you run into when you go to Salt Lake City?
Uh,
it's absolutely beautiful.
Bit of a bit of a scary landing here.
Um,
the city itself seems to be surrounded on at least three sides by a mountain.
You know,
like the old Denver Broncos,
horseshoe shaped stadium where,
you know,
when they'd go to kick the field goal,
you could see the parking lot on one side and then all you saw was a bunch of
fucking orange painted maniacs on the other.
Um,
by the way,
I never understood why they did that.
The horseshoe shaped stadium.
It was,
I just always struck me as such a half ass job where it's just like,
why don't you just finish the fucking thing?
You know?
Or just keep bleaches on both sides have it be symmetrical.
I actually know somebody who builds a lot of shit and he sucks at it.
He's good at it,
but he sucks at he's,
he wants to do everything himself and protecting the identity of this person.
But the dude read did his fucking kitchen and I walked in and I'm,
I'm eyeballing the cabinets and you can see clearly one of the cabinets is like
an eighth of an inch or a half an inch.
Like it just looks weird.
You can tell that it's longer than the other one.
And the guys I guy and I don't,
I don't like symmetry.
I'm not,
I'm not into symmetry with
thinking in my head about who's not in dissymmetry.
I could see in landscaping,
it doesn't look natural.
If everything's symmetrical on both sides,
I get that.
But when you're building something,
say you're not a dissymmetry isn't for all my construction fans out people.
And then the construction arts is,
and what that person is really saying that they don't like to measure or they
don't like to go back and fix their mistakes.
So they just sort of plow ahead.
That's basically what this fucking thing looked like.
And all I'm thinking is,
okay,
if that's what the cabinets look like,
what does the electrical look like?
You know?
And I immediately wanted to get the fuck out of there.
But anyways,
let me back up for a second here.
Um,
so when you come out here to Utah,
uh,
yeah,
so they got,
they got like,
I think it feels like it's,
it's surrounded on at least two sides.
All right.
Like that Winnipeg football stadium that I saw that,
I guess everyone is,
they're going to tear down.
Well,
they had bleachers on both sides,
nothing in either end zone,
and it just looked cold as fuck if you went to the game.
Um,
so it's,
you know,
and especially this time of year when it's a,
when it starts to get hot out,
I don't know why,
but like it tosses you around a little bit as you,
as you come in for a landing and a,
so I'm on the plane and this fucking lady in front of me might've had the worst
tattoo I've ever seen in my life and it went all the way across her back.
It was like this,
it was green ink and it was some sort of tree or some sort of something.
It's like Jesus Christ,
we get it.
You know,
you're fucked.
You like nature.
Okay.
I don't understand.
It's like I liked the Bruins,
but I would never get a giant be put on my back.
Okay.
What would you do that it stands for bill and the approach?
No,
it stands for fucking moron.
Um,
it was just a horribly,
horribly like,
uh,
you know,
my parents left when I was four years old,
just drawn like,
you know,
my buddy who sells meth,
did this tattoo.
And I've noticed that there are a lot of tattoos out here.
A lot of bad fucking tattoo.
So if you're,
if you're on that show,
what does it fix my tattoo,
Tattoo mistakes,
whatever the hell it is.
That one where you guys always draw the flowers over,
you sending me Sam fucking daffy duck in the ass.
Whatever.
Somebody could decided to get on their butt cheek.
Right?
You'd come to Utah.
Okay.
I mean I,
I don't eat,
I don't even know what,
why would you just further fuck the thing up?
Okay.
I guess the,
the guy gets,
because you're trying to draw something over it that,
that makes it creative.
I mean,
I think that they should just paratroop a bunch of people in here who were in
tattoo removal,
you know,
and uh,
just have like,
you know,
when they dropped the tanks and with that flat piece of wood underneath it,
just have the tattoo removal machine and you set up a tent like mash and he'd
just have all these people come in with their awful green tattoo tattoos and you
just remove them and then you immediately take them into another 10 and you
start showing them,
uh,
you know,
just video footage of what a good tattoo looks like,
or maybe some art or maybe give him a plane ticket and you,
and you get them to travel outside of,
outside of these fucking trees.
So they stopped drawing them on their bodies.
So am I being too judgmental?
Am I,
well,
maybe all,
yeah,
I don't know.
You don't what this is,
this really has nothing to do with the fucking two women that I saw in Utah with
those tattoos.
So I judge all fucking,
you know,
whatever,
half a million women that live in the greater Salt Lake City area has really
nothing to do with it.
Has to do with the fact that I am taping a special,
a standup special,
uh,
this Friday night in Atlanta at the tabernacle,
three theater,
two shows.
And,
um,
I'm getting fucking antsy,
so I'm lashing out of people and that,
so I apologize to,
you know,
the 99.5% of salt lake women that don't have fucking green tattoos.
I'm also being a cunt because I haven't booze since the day I came back from
France,
which was April 18th,
uh,
coming up on fucking 60 days or whatever.
I'm working out,
I look good,
but I,
I,
you know,
as far as you know,
best I can do it.
46.
Okay,
let's not get crazy here.
Okay.
Um,
I,
uh,
yeah,
I just want to take this fucking thing.
So,
um,
I get two more shows tonight here in Salt Lake City at wise,
which I gotta tell you,
man,
underrated,
underrated for the week.
Wiseguys comedy club and Salt Lake City,
Utah.
And from what I heard Joe Rogan's coming out here in the next week or so.
Um,
I guess Dave Attell was out here and went on Rogan's podcast and uh,
Joe's great podcast and you know,
and Dave was raving about this place.
So Joe called up the next day and I guess he got a booking out here and uh,
so I dunno man.
I got it.
I can see why David towl was raving about it.
It's just,
it's perfect if I can say it's a fucking perfect comedy club that the ceiling,
that the exact rate height,
the way people are seated around you,
the way they dropped the checks,
the whole fucking thing.
It's just great.
Um,
if I,
if I was actually going to design a comedy club,
did you just ask that from your fucking a elliptical machine?
You know what I would do?
I would do everything that they got there at,
uh,
at,
at wise guys,
the only money,
the only thing I would change,
I would have,
I would design it with a grain room is right off the stage.
That way,
if it was a mean crowd and maybe only you almost got into a physical
confrontation with somebody,
you have the option of not having to walk the gauntlet and go through the crowd
and you can just step right off stage and you're right into the green room.
Jim,
much like the punchline in Atlanta,
which is great,
although you can't lock the door as far as I know,
but it's still nice.
There used to be a comedy club in New York City called comics and that thing was
a fucking fortress.
I guess you could run through the curtain,
but even then there was a door down the end of the hall.
You,
you walked off stage and you step down immediately.
You are in a hallway.
If you went to the right,
you could go out and say hello to the crowd or you could go to the left and you
could disappear into the green room.
And,
uh,
you know,
this week I haven't been coming out after shows just because,
I got my special coming up and uh,
you know,
he'd go out and you shake a bunch of hands.
God knows people did,
God knows what is all over their fucking hands after you shake a bunch of hands.
And uh,
I,
I can't be getting sick this week,
so,
um,
so whatever.
That's what I've been doing this week than eating as perfect as I know how to
eat.
You know,
as I know,
that's the key thing is I know how to eat,
cause I've only partially read up on nutrition,
but uh,
I'm trying to go veggie the whole time.
I'm out here and eat a bunch of beans and all I fucking Shit I got to tell you
is my pet peeve about veggie restaurants.
Two things.
One,
um,
when you look up vegetarian restaurants,
the amount of times that it comes up with like,
I guess I don't,
I actually explained this to me.
Why do I always get like Chinese restaurants and Thai food restaurants?
And to me it's like,
okay,
I get that there's no meat in that dish,
but this salt is through the fucking roof.
And don't get me wrong,
I love Thai food.
All right.
Chinese food.
I don't know.
All right.
Shiny shoots a little shady in my book.
Um,
but like,
you know,
I like eating.
That's that shit.
He,
you know,
when you just like,
let's just fucking,
who gives a fuck?
Let's eat this food.
You know,
it's like when I,
when I asked her,
the fucking Siri,
their robot lady there,
my phone,
you know,
and I asked to said vegetarian restaurants,
Salt Lake City,
like all of a sudden all these,
these Chinese and Thai restaurants come up and it's just like,
can't you tell I'm trying to eat healthy.
I don't need a of fucking noodles.
Was Salt poured all over it.
That's not what the fuck I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to get down on my fighting weight here.
So anyway,
so then I,
I had to go and like Vegan restaurants,
that type of thing.
Here's my pet peeve with Vega fucking restaurants.
The goddamn things have weird hours.
All right.
I,
there's two of them within walking distance of my hotel and neither one of them
is open Sunday.
Neither one of them is open.
Every fucking burger joint from here to fucking Colorado Springs is open.
God Damn Vegan restaurants,
how come they're not open on Sundays?
And you know what?
A lot of carnivores would say it's because to a weekday a care they need to
rush.
Judge started daycare it.
Yeah.
Nothing gives you less energy and less energy than eating in a healthy way.
That's,
I'm so fucking sick of that shit.
And people talking about electric cars look good.
They go up a hill,
you know?
That's why I'm really,
I'm starting to,
I'm starting to pull away from the whole conspiracy theory thing.
I think the whole thing just works itself,
you know?
Because there's just enough people out there that know,
don't know shit.
Myself included.
Jesus Christ.
I'm top 10 on that list.
And you just,
it's just,
it's a,
yeah.
It's really not like a group of people live in under a mountain.
It's just a bunch of mouth breathing.
Morons or not even people who just died all fucking know anything.
You know,
like I've been talking about,
I want to learn how to fly a helicopter and people keep saying [inaudible] to
that man.
Those things have fallen out of the sky all the time.
They're really all the time and everybody's okay with that.
Just every other Mary can't come into work today.
Yeah.
Helicopter fell out of the fucking sky did happen to her again.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
it fucking happens.
It happened in Scotland this past year of one fell on a bar.
Horrible story.
But I mean obviously,
I mean shit happens.
Okay Shit.
But Shit happens on the ground too.
You know how many times a day to people step on a rake,
right.
Does that mean you leave the leaves out there and burn up your grass?
I don't think it does,
Dude.
It's a fucking engine cuts out yet all that's it.
You fuck a dog?
You just dropped like a stone.
No,
you don't.
You don't.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Look it up.
Just look it up,
right?
You fucking auto rotate.
Like I'm saying that like I know how to do it.
Um,
although I have watched people on Youtube doing,
it's pretty,
uh,
it's pretty fucking impressive for whatever,
whatever.
I'm,
look,
I'm by brain is all over the fucking place this week.
I
okay.
Can't stand the weight the week of to do my special.
All right.
I am,
I am ready right now.
I'm actually sitting here in my boxes and my t shirt and I am ready to throw in
some slacks and a shirt.
And if I walked out my hotel room and they just passed me on,
Mike and my began my special,
nothing would make me happier.
All right.
This is,
it's like I,
it's like I just want to get out there and fucking do this God damn thing
because the second it's over.
Oh,
fucking red faces on vacation.
I'm on vacation.
Everybody for the first time.
Emma,
I'm taking,
I'm taking the summer,
basically taking the summer off.
I've got a couple of gigs here or there,
but I am,
I'm dialing it back,
you know,
and by taking off the summer,
I mean,
I'm not going to be jumping on a bunch of airplanes.
I'm going to be a course in the comedy clubs out here in La,
trying to build up my next hour before my next special comes out.
But I'll be sleeping in my own bed.
I'm going to be getting drunk in my own house.
I'm going to be putting on all the weight that I took off from my special in a
neighborhood restaurants.
I'm gonna have a great time becoming old Billy fat face again.
You know right now a malaria William.
Okay,
now don't get too skinny.
I love it.
People say that to you.
Don't get to fucking skinny.
It's like if I lifted up my shirt and you saw the horror show that's underneath
it,
you're just used to me being really out of shape.
Now I'm only kind of out of shape or right.
But believe me,
Calvin Klein will not be calling me ever.
You understand?
Which really disappoints me because I think it's about time.
They did a spread of a 46 year old,
redheaded male shirtless.
Okay.
So if they're listening,
all right,
I'm throwing my fucking hat in the ring.
How bad,
how bad with this stock.
Plage yeah,
either way.
You'd never know because I used to watch a watch that top model show with Nia,
you know,
I mean I got to find a middle ground.
So it's like if you're gonna Watch some reality,
at least I can look at some,
you know,
beautiful nine foot women walking around with a look on their face.
Like you know somebody Pete and their Okra.
Right?
And uh,
okay,
so many of them,
they will,
they,
they were beautiful bodies,
but they have faces.
They were fucking weird.
So I finally said to Nia,
I'm like,
you know what the fuck is what,
why,
what is with her fucking,
she looks like she put on an astronaut helmet that was too small,
you know,
when she left it on for like 24 hours and they just just pop the thing off right
now,
you know?
And she's just like,
well,
you know,
Tyra likes,
she likes him.
She thinks they should be a little weird looking.
And I was just like,
what?
What,
why is that?
So she doesn't feel intimidated.
You know,
what's her problem?
She's been on the cover of sports illustrated or she tried to help other people
because used to make fun of her forehead.
You know,
I love that people made fun of tire banks,
his forehead,
you know,
like if she came walking up to you,
right.
Doing that thing where one leg stepping over the other leg for some dumb reason.
Okay.
I,
you know something,
I have to be honest with you.
No matter how good a woman looked,
if they came walking up to me like that during the stepping over each other foot
each,
you know,
every other foot,
why would it fuck I'm trying to say right over left,
left over right with that look on their face with their hair blowing.
Um,
that's supposed to look so amazing.
If that actually happened to me in real life,
I would be sitting there looking at them.
Do you guys ever see young Frankenstein?
Okay.
You know,
I remember when gene Wilder's going,
it said a lie is a lie,
you know,
and Frankenstein's just kind of sitting there looking at him like,
what the fuck is wrong with this dude?
That that's how I would be looking at.
I'm not saying you know,
that they're not beautiful,
but whatever.
I'm,
I'm fucking making too many left turns here.
I don't even know how it got to this.
I was talking about weird looking.
Oh yeah.
So I,
I'm weird looking.
I'm a weird looking fucker.
Who knows?
Maybe it could have,
I know that it does that work.
Yeah,
I guess it does work.
I was thinking maybe it wouldn't work,
uh,
women into weird looking guys
and not from my experience.
No Kid.
That was kitten hope.
You know,
what are they into?
They want,
they want security.
And that translates to money because that's how the fucking world works.
So are they really hoarse?
I Dunno when we return and I'm all right,
I'm going to a pause here now actually don't have my advertising,
so I'm gonna have to record it later and drop it in.
So right now I have to pause so I have a place to fucking edit this into.
All right.
Legal Zoom.
Every one America was built by innovators and dreamers.
People like Thomas Edison and Henry Ford laid the foundation for our country.
These days.
It's the inventors and the entrepreneurs all around us like you that keep our
country running by fueling the job,
market and economy.
This month,
legal zoom celebrates innovation by helping you launch your dream.
Apply for a patent to secure your inner your invention.
Register your trademark to protect your products and services.
Incorporate or form an LLC and launch your business.
Visit Legal zoom.com and use discount code Burrell,
Bu Rr.
They'll provide the personal attention you need and help take care of all the
details.
They've helped over a million businesses gets sanded,
right.
And then they received an a plus from the better business bureau.
Celebrate innovation with legal zoom today and get a special price on trademark
copyright.
A provisional patent applications by using the discount code bur bur at checkout
legal zoom provides legal help through independent attorneys and self help,
but they are not a law firm.
legalzoom.com discount code burr and lastly,
but not leastly Hulu plus everyone.
You've probably tried Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu plus you can watch current seasons,
uh,
episodes of your favorite shows like modern family,
the daily show in scandal and watch every episode of shows like Nashville loss
and doctor who,
uh,
you get ad free movies and kids shows to now more than ever,
there's so much to watch.
Take total control with Hulu plus to stream these shows and thousands more,
as much as you want,
whenever you want.
Hulu plus works on your computer,
your smartphone,
TV,
Roku,
apple TV.
I'm sorry,
your smart TV.
That's smart phones,
smart TV,
Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox,
playstation.
Pretty much any streaming device you already on,
you can even watch on your phone or iPad while I guess they can then,
Huh?
While on the train at work at the dentist or in the bathroom,
you can even block off a day to bench.
He also get to,
uh,
to access originals that you cannot get anywhere else.
Check out the new show dead.
Beat a comedy about a pot smoking guy who talks to ghost.
You can binge on all 10 episodes starting April 9th for only seven 99 a month.
Get your shows anytime,
anywhere.
That's like a quarter a day.
Come on folks.
Sign up now.
Right now,
sign up at Hulu plus.com/bill or click the banner on my website and get two
weeks full access.
Completely free.
That's a whole extra week more with this special offer when you sign up at Hulu
plus.com/bill oh wait,
I've got the money.
So get with it and start streaming TV now with Hulu plus I'm the worst.
Yeah.
Okay.
And we are back.
We are back.
I hope you enjoyed that read.
I hope I did a good job on it.
All right.
Because I'm reading that sometime in the future.
MMM.
So anyways,
I've been a,
you know,
with my fucking add,
I've been trying to learn how to,
you know,
just work out more efficiently or fucking whatever.
So I've been eating right and that type of thing.
And I've gotten into all of these,
uh,
you know,
I like climbing the rope and doing pull ups and shit.
And I stumbled onto a couple of youtube videos.
Of course I don't have them up here,
but I'll definitely send the links to uh,
to Andrew to have them up here.
Um,
couple of these home home gyms you could have in the garage and um,
and,
and one,
this one,
it's actually part is a three part series with this guy teaches you how to do a
muscle up,
which is basically if you ever saw somebody do the pull up and they basically go
passage and up to their chest and then basically get to the point where they do
a dip at the top of the bar,
that the,
the,
the other half of a dip because you don't have to go down because you start out.
Just explain that in a completely confusing,
you know what I mean?
You shoot pass the bar and then you push yourself up with your arms so your arms
are then straight at the top of the bar.
And I remember the first time I tried to do that,
if you could have listened to the [inaudible],
do you remember when,
uh,
what's his face?
William Wallace was getting his end trails yanked out.
Okay.
Do you remember that noise Mel Gibson was making,
if you could fucking take that audio and then turn it up to a,
you know,
when they do the chipmunks holiday records.
That's what I sounded like when I tried to do on,
aside from the fact that I completely lack the strength,
um,
my technique,
I didn't understand that very little of it.
Is your arms going past that?
Uh,
that bar and I'm not even going to try to begin to explore why?
Well,
my head was supposed to be funny on this one and I tried to explain it.
It's basically you're calming up when you're,
when you're pulling yourself up,
you sort of explode up and you got yet your legs are a little bit in front of
you and then right as you,
you get your chest up to the bar,
you do a quick shit up in the air,
I swear to God,
which causes your legs to swing down like a down past.
You like a fucking pendulum and you actually roll up onto the bar.
So it's really,
it's your abs sitting up and then your legs swinging out from underneath you
that gets you up over the bar and then your arms are in positions position to,
uh,
to then push yourself up.
And it's like,
oh,
that's why I was fucking up.
So I figure,
I figure if I just,
you know,
train doing that for two months over the summer,
trying to get my technique down right.
And then I somehow,
you know,
jump into the cocoon pool.
I had to be able to do it by 2016 what do you think?
Maybe do the human slag one of those fucking things.
I'm just fascinated with people that have that kind of strength.
And then I found a,
I don't know,
you just click on that.
Then the other things that they suggest,
I clicked on like five others and all of a sudden I was watching these guys
climbing what was considered the hardest rock face to climb in the world.
And these fucking guys,
I mean I bitch about doing pull ups,
you know,
I got my whole hand around it.
These guys get like that,
you know the little joint at the top of your finger.
They're hanging on like that and they jump up to a thing and they like for their
fingers,
that last little joint,
a grabbing some little crevice and I'm telling you,
they reach up and they grab it and you and the people on the ground here all the
way on the ground.
You have the guy jumps up and he grabs me just here,
do that the whole fucking way up.
They got a grip called the pinch grip.
Just imagine holding a dictionary or a really thick book,
right?
And you just sort of would hold it straight down.
You know,
on either side of it,
you're just holding it by the binding.
Yeah,
like that kind of a grip.
Like the lobster grip and the,
the thing is like,
it's uh,
it's,
it's faced up and down.
What's the fucking word?
Perpendicular.
I have no idea.
It's looks like a nose coming out of the fucking cliff and they jump up and grab
one of those and then just pinch with their fucking hand
and then they get one little toe cracked below it.
Just holding that.
I mean,
watching these guys do this shit.
I swear to God it's like these guys.
Okay.
I mean I,
I don't know,
like if you ever had them in prison,
it's like how long could you keep them in prison
the second you got them in the yard,
you'd have to have a fucking scope on them at all times because they would just
fucking run over to the corner.
Well,
we're one wall meets together wall and he's a little 90 degree turn.
Okay.
They just kinda put all the way up the top of it.
Next thing.
You know that thing be right in your face,
like that fucking grizzly bear that ran up that tree.
Have you seen that youtube video?
This guy's sitting,
he's in a fucking tree.
Well,
like a bow and Arrow trained on this black bear and the black bear looks up and
sees him and within two seconds it runs up the tree next to him and is above
them.
Okay.
And they're sitting there like,
God,
dude,
what the fuck?
Holy Shit.
What the fuck?
They're like freaking out and I'm
okay.
I don't know why.
Okay.
I was rooting for the bear.
I wanted the bear to mall that guy.
I just think it's fucked up to go out and shoot a bear or an elk or a moose.
You know what I mean?
Can we just keep it with cows and chickens?
Isn't that enough?
Yeah.
Fish.
Okay.
Yeah.
All the fish to get fucking killed.
I swear to God,
I swear to God.
The more,
the more I,
I,
okay.
I don't know.
I look into that shit.
It's,
it's just brutal.
You know where I go hiking in,
uh,
California when I hike.
And by the way,
I do wear short shorts with aerobics socks.
When I hike
there's a fucking mountain lion.
Okay.
There's a mountain lion in the canyon
and that's been freaking me out.
And they have these cameras set up all over the place and over the last couple
of years of taking pictures of them,
they just took a picture of the thing recently.
And I swear to God it looks horrible.
And what they're speculating it happened,
happened is to thing is eating coyotes that eat rats,
that eat the rat poison that people put out,
you know,
to kill the rats.
And if you saw this thing,
you know,
I am terrified of getting malt.
Okay?
I'm terrified of the ocean getting eaten by a shark,
getting pulled up by the riptide and getting mauled,
any of that fucking shit.
Any shit that involves me.
Okay?
I just can't imagine when one of those cats is,
you're walking right?
Just reaches out and you okay.
Just in terms you wanted to like this rag doll,
how little fucking control you have,
your ability to fight back.
It's like,
dude,
you're fighting fucking Edward Scissorhands but fast,
you know,
or like Freddy Krueger on all feet.
Just that alone.
If it gets scratched by a fucking house cat.
Okay.
It fucking kills.
Can you imagine a god Damn Mountain Line just grabbing you and pulling you over
to it's fucking mouth.
Ah,
God.
Feeling that breath on your neck.
Jesus Christ.
I'm fucking terrified of those things.
That's just a mountain line,
which is like a house cat compared to what?
Tiger.
Right.
So,
but I saw the things face.
It's just like that.
That's terrible.
Yeah.
It's fucking terrible,
man.
So I don't know.
I'm not trying to get all pita on you here.
I didn't want to talking about it.
I'm all over the fucking place this week.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm going to,
I'm really want to get you guys those clips because uh,
there's three clips I want to show you that it really inspired me to try and get
back.
And you know,
I don't know if you just stop walking around with this 15 pounds of pizza and
beer.
Wait,
just fucking sick of it.
You know,
I've knocked off like half of it.
I just don't understand how far down I got to go to have a flat stomach again.
He can't even do it once.
You'll be,
once you get that fucking belly,
it's just over and you try to fucking lose the weight and you just lose muscle
and no matter how you eat a hope,
God damn chicken,
somehow you fucking arms are going to shrink.
And you have Belize just going to be sitting there laughing at yeah.
Juggling.
You know,
it was funny actually got a fucking email this week
and I know you guys are saying,
Jesus,
Bill,
you have made a major body issues.
Yeah,
I do.
Well,
you know what,
why don't you get a good gig?
Get on fucking comedy central's premium blend.
Why don't you do that and then get yourself a fucking Twitter account and let me
tell you what kind of body images you're going to have people on exactly.
Nice to you.
Um,
they start off nice,
a really funny shit,
but what's the deal with?
And then you ended up getting like,
oh fuck,
I never even noticed that about myself.
So anyways,
here's somebody says a fat shaming bones Yogi,
Ohm French for William Mary.
I actually knew that one.
Showing up.
How Keel,
uh,
Ramo,
I am a longtime listener and I love the show.
I am a big guy and fat shaming works.
It really works.
Last September I was sneaking a pizza in my car while listening to the show and
you add another rant about fat people and you basically described exactly what I
was doing.
Like you,
you were somehow watching me eat.
It made me laugh uncontrollably and I decided to get serious about losing
weight.
I quit boozing,
which is something you're show inspired me to do and ate healthy and exercise
twice a day.
Uh,
I was off the bottle from until February.
And spending the holidays sober was quite a challenge.
But I got my weight down from three 10 to two 54 dote.
Graduations,
what is that?
Let's do the math here for this guys.
61 pounds times five miles of capillaries for every fucking pound.
That's 305 miles of less of capillaries that your heart has to beat every time.
Isn't that wonderful?
We'll be right back on Doctor Oz.
Sorry everybody.
Uh,
I was pleased with my progress and I started working out less and resumed
drinking til mid April when I weighed myself at two 73 so I gained 19 pounds in
about two and a half months of drinking.
I was shocked.
Therefore,
I am off alcohol again and,
and,
and way to 43 now.
Holy Shit.
He says,
my goal is to weigh to 10 before I drink again,
please continue to make criticizing.
Uh Oh,
please continue to criticize the fat ass is because you do it in a hilarious yet
respectful way.
Thank you for your help.
Oh Dude,
that's great man.
You know what's great about what you did was a lot of people,
if they went from three 10 to two 54 and they started,
you know,
going back to that bad habits,
you then,
you know,
gain it all back.
And then some,
I'm surprised you weren't three 20 self.
And so the fact that you actually,
uh,
got back on the scale at two 73 shows a,
you got a lot of willpower,
then you dropped another 30 after that.
So what do you down altogether?
Two 43 that's 57 and 10 is 67 pounds.
Dude,
that's amazing man.
That's amazing.
Uh,
well if you go back to boozing,
what I would suggest is,
uh,
drinking whiskey or Scotch neat.
You know,
a drinking vodka on the rocks or something.
Just,
it's Kinda,
that's like the vaporizer of boozing.
You just get right to it.
Like all those chick drinks,
um,
not only you,
the,
you,
you're,
you're sucking down,
you get a brutal fucking hangover first of all,
and then it's just all this extra bullshit,
you know,
rum and cokes,
you have five rum and cokes.
Would you ever sit down and drink five cokes?
I can barely finish one.
Have to.
Wow.
It's,
it's,
I can feel my stomach expanding like him in some hot dog eating contest.
Um,
so yeah,
I would go,
I would go back to that and then,
um,
I would somehow limits,
uh,
your intake of it,
which I gotta be honest with you.
I don't know how to do because,
uh,
speaking of boozing,
okay,
there's a segue for you.
Um,
so here's the deal.
I basically said I wasn't going to drink it til my special,
so I'll be done with my special Friday night.
And then I was kinda thinking like,
well,
you know what,
I want to close out June,
you know,
cause I didn't drink for the entire month of February or May.
And if I get June then I'm kind of balanced out.
Right.
I drank January,
March,
and April didn't drink February,
May and June.
So I'm kind of,
you know,
I'm fucking got the ying and Yang of being a drug douche and actually being
sober.
But,
uh,
the thing is,
is the last weekend in June,
I'm at,
uh,
I'm at the Mirage in Las Vegas and it's not going to be hard not to drink,
you know,
cause I don't,
I don't gamble.
You know what I mean?
I'm too fucking old to go hang out and do that type of shift.
If I'm going to booze,
I would just go back and drink by myself in the hotel room,
which is,
I'm not going to do.
However.
Excuse me,
how to take a drink of water there.
Um,
coincidentally,
and I don't know how this happened.
The all in tour starring Joe Barton,
Nick,
Jason,
law head and Paul don't say I'm from New Jersey.
Versie is going to be there on the Sunday night.
I'm there Friday and Saturday.
I can't fucking believe it.
They're going to be right across the street,
you know,
so what am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do?
What?
What do,
I'm not going to hang out with them.
And you know what's funny that's going to be like June 28th or 29th,
and uh,
the one at 1:00 AM I going to do,
you know,
I got to do it.
So I'm going to go over there and uh,
I'll tell you where,
it's funny as I've been dying for some Miller high life,
there's something about the bottle.
I didn't think the beer tastes that good.
It's just the best bottle ever.
You know,
it looks like a fucking lady
and there's a part of me to relate to you sir.
I don't want to go back.
I miss it man.
I fucking love drinking.
But uh,
I like how I feel not drinking,
but,
um,
I dunno man.
As I said Diversey before,
whatever the fuck I said about the devil in me,
the devil is a
devil is rearing his fucking ugly head.
I can't remember what the fuck I said to him,
but I,
I feel it like I need to.
What I'm hoping to do is just get absolutely plastered with them and then
immediately go back to,
uh,
sort of,
not being an idiot and then actually doing these workouts that I was telling you
guys about any of might think I'm obsessed with this stuff,
but I am,
I mean,
who wants to be a fat fuck nobody,
you know,
don't you want to be in good question though.
All right.
Aren't,
I don't,
I don't need to get into this shit with you guys.
You know,
you're a bunch of adults.
Um,
yeah,
I felt shamed myself all the fucking time and it fuck it works.
All right,
well let's get beyond this.
Let's,
let's move in a different direction.
Let's read another,
uh,
wait,
before we do that,
I haven't even talked about anything.
Let's swap out thought about,
let's talk a little bit of hockey.
All right.
First and foremost,
all crown the La Kings,
the kings claim the crown second time in three years.
You know what's weird is I thought the Blackhawks were going to win it and they
were going to say that they were going to be a dynasty.
Okay.
If they want three,
cause that would have been 2010,
2014,
13 2014.
So they would have one,
one,
they want one,
three and five years.
And they're saying how competitive with all the free agents signings and all
that bullshit,
um,
three and five years would now be considered a dynasty.
So guess who's in line for next year?
The unthinkable.
The La kings a couple of years ago,
you know,
we're actually more than that four fucking years ago.
The La Kings fan base was thinking,
are we ever going to fucking win one?
I bet if you talked to their fan base,
they will probably go and like,
dude,
I just want to see him when it wants.
They just went at once in my lifetime,
I am going to be happy.
Yeah,
Yada Yada,
Yada Yada.
And here we are four or five short years later.
If they win it again next year,
that would be,
let's see,
they would want it in,
uh,
2012.
Then Chicago 1415,
they would have one,
three and four years where they get the Patriots a dynasty.
So that would definitely be considered a dynasty.
And I know unbelievable what a fucking team,
you know.
And I also got to say hats off to the rangers cause everybody thought like the
east was a lot weaker than they were.
And despite the fact that they lost in five games,
I mean three of those ranger losses were an overtime.
Um,
I definitely think the kings were clearly the better team,
but I just being a,
you know,
a Bruins Fan,
I was happy that the east,
you know,
we didn't get absolutely shelled.
The only tough game it was if you arrange a fan to watch was that game a game
three when they lost three to nothing where they really just got shut down and a
game four I missed because I was working.
I think that's one of the Rangers won two to one,
but whatever man,
it was great.
It's a great season.
And um,
Jim Rome actually tweeted something where he said,
uh,
you know,
once something to the,
I retweeted it,
something to the effect that once again,
the Nhl playoffs just show,
you know,
just saying that basically that they were the best playoffs.
Now I'm not going to be someone who says that.
I mean I think they are,
but I understand if it's not your sport,
but I'm telling you it's fucking insane.
Um,
but however,
I have also been watching the NBA finals and I actually watched both conference
finals and I've been enjoying that too.
And,
uh,
how bout them spurs look into close at home and you guys know whether they did
or not.
Um,
I won't know because a,
it's the fucking afternoon here.
By the time I post this,
I dunno who the fuck knows.
All I know is,
uh,
it's been amazing to watch the spurs fucking great team.
How about that Leonard Kit?
Jesus Christ.
You know what I like about him?
The one clip that I saw,
he shows up to the arena looking like he's going to go play basketball as
opposed to everybody else who for some reason show they show up like the,
they're going to fucking foreclose on somebody's house.
Why do they wear the suits?
It's like if you're to wear the suit,
then you ought to do it.
Like,
uh,
you know,
Walt Frazier,
and I'm using that reference cause I actually,
yeah,
I'm going to get a little Hollywood on you,
but I'm doing it because I'm promoting a friend of mine's a
new documentary.
Michael Rapaport was nice enough to invite me to the premiere of a screening of
it.
He's that.
He's got a new documentary out called when the garden was Eaton based on a book
by the same name that was about the 70,
um,
and 73 New York knick championship teams and basically the building of that
championship team and um,
all his lot of overlap when I actually,
you know,
just knowing some of the rangers history,
the same thing where,
um,
the Knicks just weren't even respected.
And that same thing,
just like the New York Rangers,
like right around when playoff time came around,
Madison Square Garden also brought the circus and the circus would sell more
tickets than the ranges of the next wood.
And uh,
so they would have to play like one year that the New York Rangers,
I forget it,
what the fuck they were playing.
I think they were playing the Detroit Pistons,
the Detroit Redwings jumping sports here.
The Detroit Redwings in the Stanley Cup final and the circus was in town in
Madison Square Garden,
wouldn't let them play their home games in Madison Square Garden.
So they actually had in play,
I believe it was in maple leaf gardens with the Toronto Maple leafs played.
They considered that somewhat of a home game because leaf fans hated a wings
fans and they thought that leaf fans maybe would show up and root for the
rangers.
Um,
there's a lot of that type of stuff.
you really should see it if you get a chance.
I don't know.
I don't have a premiere date yet,
but I'm going to try to get him on the podcast again.
Longtime listeners.
Remember his last is only visit to the podcast where he trashed me for the
giants beat and the Patriots in the Superbowl and all New York fans of course,
enjoy,
enjoyed that.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But um,
it's,
it's a fucking amazing documentary.
And one of the funniest things about it without giving anything away is
listening to Rapaport trying to debate these guys and to trashing Boston and
their fans.
It's fucking hilarious.
Um,
so he definitely check it out.
It's going to be on,
he did.
It was one of those ESPN 30 for 30,
60 for 60.
I don't know what the hell it is,
but it's,
it's amazing.
It's called when the garden was eating.
All right.
Is That my horn out?
Enough things this week?
You know,
how about this,
I got another one for you that I actually watched downloaded legally paid my $5.
I watched David spades new stand up special called my fake problems.
Um,
definitely check that one out.
What I loved about it was I actually,
you know,
it's still his,
classic David Spade,
but I felt it was really personal stuff.
Um,
like I,
I easily his best specialties ever put out.
So if you're a fan of his or a new fan or curious man,
it was definitely worth the five bucks.
Um,
and that's,
that's one of my bucket list things.
I want to see that guy live at some point.
But anyway,
so let's go,
let's get back to the,
let's get back to the podcast here.
Um,
what else?
What else have I been doing here?
I've been watching some world cup soccer.
My fucking TV just went out in the hotel room,
so I was watching France.
They were up three,
three to nothing trois to a zero.
Whoever the fuck you say zero.
And uh,
I dunno,
I get into the World Cup.
I think it's fucking awesome.
And I do think soccer was a beautiful sport.
Uh,
I just don't understand why my co,
my complaint that I've always had with that fucking sport,
I don't give a shit about the lack of goals.
Shit.
I watch hockey.
I still understand,
understands it's think it's awesome.
I just don't understand why every fucking two minutes somebody collapses to the
ground.
Like they blew out their ACL and all they did was get kicked in the Shin and
they have a Shin Guard there.
Now I'm not saying that I wouldn't collapse to the ground,
but I'm not a professional athlete.
You watch the fucking UFC,
those fucking maniacs kick the other fighter with that part of their leg.
Now I know they come in at an angle,
but it's still his shin.
Now if they can toughen their leg up to do,
to do that,
you know,
I don't understand why these guys can you make the fucking guard go all the way
around their legs so we can keep the movement going.
So I don't know.
I mean,
I,
I don't know.
My idea of watching the sport is not every two minutes I see a man,
a grown fucking man in the fetal position with a look on his face.
Like he's going to start crying and then somebody comes running up to another
player,
gets right in his face.
Like he's going to punch him and you're like,
oh,
great is going to be a fight.
And then he takes out this yellow card and sticks it up in the air.
Like he's in some Benny Hill sketch.
Other than that,
I love it.
The scarves,
the singing,
people going absolutely fucking nuts when they score.
I enjoy all of that.
So I'll continue watching it.
And this year is actually great to now that they,
uh,
they got it away from those crazy horns,
whatever the fuck and those things we'll call
know Jesus was Hulu.
Fuck's calling me now?
Huh?
Who is this?
Oh Jesus.
Hang on the lovely Nia.
Everybody.
Nia,
I'm recording my podcasts.
Can I call you right back?
Okay,
Sweetie.
All right.
MMM.
Anyways,
where are we here?
43 minutes.
And I could tell by the way she said,
okay,
that I need to talk to her.
She's like,
okay.
Oh Geez.
All right.
Um,
what was I talking?
World Cup soccer.
So I have no idea who's gonna win that.
All I know is I think that,
you know,
I think I've watched enough soccer to tell it to know that,
the United States is definitely without a doubt going to make the finals this
year.
If not when the whole fucking thing.
Okay,
look,
I know they're not going to win it,
but I just,
I want them to,
when it's so bad because it piss off the world on two levels.
One,
everybody fucking hates us.
So then I can enjoy us actually winning a true world championship where
everybody was invited and we were the best.
And then secondly,
when like 40 people show up to the parade,
you know,
here in the United States,
just to watch everybody having to wait another four years to wait for their team
to win it and just see that we want something that we don't even give a fuck
about.
Right.
Like some hot chick that gets a fucking,
you know,
a Bentley for fucking 16th birthday.
Okay.
And I god,
why did you get that color?
I guess it's okay.
You know,
that would be us if we ever won the fucking World Cup and I want it to happen.
I really do.
Um,
anyways,
the same way I wanted my team to draft Michael Sam and I wanted to absolutely
dominate because on two level levels it would annoy fence one that someone on my
team was dominating their team and then to all the homophobes would be upset
that this gay guy was just wreaking havoc.
All right.
Oh,
speaking a soccer,
uh,
dear Billy worldclass.
Um,
oh,
actually,
you know,
I got to pause here to reach recent more fucking,
uh,
sorry guys to read some more fucking advertise.
This is the last little group here.
Let me do my little pause.
All right.
Who's number two?
When the order a dollar shave club,
everybody,
the big razor company.
You know what?
They think we're stupid.
Oh yeah.
Every year they roll out some ridiculous shaving technology gimmick and expect
us to shell out big bucks for it.
What are they up to?
17 blades at this point.
All lifting and separating like a bra in the 70s.
Do you really need a razor with a vibrating handle?
Huh?
Well,
a roller pivot ball.
Backscratcher egg timer laser pointer corkscrew.
Huh?
I know I don't,
we were shaving just fine before any of that crap.
We were two blades.
That was all you have needed.
Uh,
you could get it on to get knows they got so many blades.
You can't even shave onto your nose.
Um,
and I definitely don't think I need to spend my hard earned cash on a people.
It's a bunch of junk.
If you're sick of being treated like a full,
like a whore,
like an idiot,
a moron,
a sucker or chump.
Join the hundreds of thousands of smarter people who joined Dollar Shave
club.com dollar shave club.com delivers the best blades and grooming supplies
for just a few bucks a month.
That blades up better than the big shape companies for a fraction of the price.
You know what?
I have sensitive skin,
so watch what you say about it when you're around it and their razors have never
given me any problems.
Honestly,
I have the best shape of my life with their four x razor.
You got to try it.
I've never used that.
Stop putting words in my mouth.
I like the double blade.
She got this sweetheart.
I told my buddy about the dollar shave club that would be guys and he shares a
subscription with his wife.
No life.
I think it's saved their marriage.
Dollar Shave Club.
Why are you writing all this crap?
You have a product that sells itself.
Quit trying to make me sound more personal.
All right.
It's personal.
The way I fuck up the reed.
Okay.
My listeners can get started now.
Dollar Shave club.com/burr and don't forget.
Next week is fucking father's day upgrade.
Pop Shave upgrade is upgrade.
Pop Shave with the Dollar Shave Club gift card because he shouldn't have to pay
more for is ridiculous.
Shave and get mixed.
Either stop getting ripped off or the big getting ripped off by the big shave
and companies joined.
Dollar Shave club.com/burr a shave club.
Dot what they wrote it three times in a row with no punctuation.
Dollar Shave club.com/bar.
Yeah.
Then it says shave club.com/bar
yeah.
I don't even understand what it is.
Dollar Shave club.com/ [inaudible] that's what it is.
B U.
R.
Okay.
This,
it's legitimate.
We don't need any bells and whistles on the snake.
Just join it.
Okay.
Unless you want to keep getting screwed.
All right.
If you like to be Gillette's prison bitch,
keep doing what you're doing.
Oh God.
Look at that.
Look at that little thing I just opened up.
Those are my French words.
I stuck with it for two months now.
I don't remember any of them.
Okay.
And I'm back here.
All right.
Um,
all right,
dear Billy,
world class,
uh,
I don't hate on soccer even though I have a problem with it.
There are some great things about the game.
Sometimes I wish I played it because it automatically,
it would mean I'd have great hair and abs apparently.
Uh,
what pros and cons would you say there are to the game of soccer?
I think I already answered this.
I,
you know,
I just love out the whole world,
loves it and we don't love it.
And then we have the nerve to sit there criticizing it rather than sitting back
going,
hey,
maybe we're wrong about this.
You know,
like the whole world's on like the fucking metric system and we're,
we're not,
you know,
God,
I know you were going to stick with the,
uh,
the foot in the FEC and yachts.
So,
uh,
anyways,
let's,
I'm,
let me hear what your complaints are.
Um,
let's see.
He says,
uh,
my biggest complaint other than the pratfalls and woosie injuries,
is that well do it well,
I gotta be honest with you.
If somebody is running full speed and steps on your,
your foot with a cleat,
I mean,
that's got to fucking hurt.
that's up there.
That's like taking an Arista off your laces.
Um,
is the fact that the reps control when the game ends,
they don't end the game until a play is over despite what the clock says.
Uh,
no,
that's,
that's the,
uh,
penalty minutes when all those guys rolling around on the ground.
So to have you relate to it,
that's like a snow day.
If you get a snow day in like elementary school,
you still have to go 180 days.
So they just tack on an extra day.
You are going to get out of school on June 20th.
Now it's the 21st.
That's how it works.
They keep track of the time.
He says,
however,
and a game yesterday I watched a possession changed twice and a yellow card
being issued.
Uh,
he puts in parentheses,
someone's stubbed their toe.
And the rep still didn't stop the game.
You think NBA reps can mess with the game?
The soccer reps got a few weapons of their own.
Um,
yeah,
I guess,
I guess they can.
Why was,
when I talk about that,
I talk about the four major American sports,
the United States of America,
what I'm talking about.
But uh,
yeah,
I guess you can give people yellow cards,
give them two yellow cards.
But I feel like the crowd kind of keeps the ref in check where,
you know,
I can NBA Ref consider player and uh,
I dunno if it was a big enough games,
maybe he'd get a couple of death threats,
but you know,
in the soccer world they'll actually carry,
they'll actually kill you.
They'll actually run out into the field and like fucking saw your head off.
Um,
there was something horrific that happened down in South America.
We'll just like 20 year old ref.
First of all,
he had a knife on him so he can tell you what kind of a fucking horrific
refereeing job he knew he was going into.
And he got into it with some guy and I don't know what happened,
but he took out a knife and he stabbed this guy and I believe the guy died.
And then his brother,
the dude who died,
his brother and everybody else ran onto the field and they cut the dude's head
off on the fucking soccer field,
you know?
And we flip out when Ron Artest goes into the crowd and throws 15 punches and
doesn't connect once basketball players are the worst.
They can't draw a fucking,
you know what it is?
It's because they were nine feet tall in the third grade.
They didn't have to fight.
I,
some of the shorter guys,
this six foot ones,
you know,
they knew how to fight,
but I swear to God,
first of all,
they'd throw punches like they're trying to throw somebody out from like the
warning track.
They do that overhand fucking,
a lot of them,
lot of them,
they,
they uh,
I don't know what the deal is.
That would be fucking scary,
right?
If you actually learned some martial arts.
I know Kareem Abdul Jabbar tried to act like he did in those Bruce Lee movies,
or maybe a will Chamberlain in a Conan the barbarian.
Did he fight in that thing?
And he just sort of sit on that fucking Yak?
I can't remember.
Um,
anyways,
I don't,
I don't really,
uh,
I'm not gonna criticize a,
I'm not gonna Criticize World Cup soccer.
The whole fucking world loves it.
I understand that there's something wrong with me.
And you know,
I went to a game when I was over in England,
went to that arsenal game and the knock,
a lot of it was the shit.
It was the shit.
We just don't have enough time
to get into it.
You know,
like I would say if,
if you're,
if you're into sports in the United States,
you're into football and you're in the basketball for them,
or you're into football and you were into hockey.
All right,
and maybe you watch a little bit of baseball.
That's how,
that's kind of where the pendulum is right now.
But there's very few people that can actually watch hockey and basketball at the
same,
like the,
the amount of space that would be taken up on your fucking Divia.
Right.
I used to do it back in the day though,
back in the 80s,
man,
we had bird,
mchale,
Robert Parish,
you know,
fucking uh,
Dennis Johnson,
Cedric Maxwell,
m l cow,
right.
And then the Bruins
all through the eighties to the ending of Stan,
Jonathan Wayne Cash Terrio Riley and to Cam Neely Raymond Bork,
right,
Gord clues,
exec Willie Plett,
Linden bias,
all of those fucking guys.
You didn't want to miss a game least I used to just,
okay,
so all you did,
just that,
that's why I suck so bad in school side from the fact that I was dumb was,
you know,
the beginning of the year,
school year,
it was football season.
So that fucked half my weekend right through January.
And by January I was in the throes of hockey and basketball season.
That shit ended around May.
And then it was June.
And then I would just say,
hey,
you know,
maybe I'll try next year,
and then what happened?
Then I'd go to summer school,
summer school,
what a fucking great time that was.
Why don't you just got past the fact that you was still going to school?
What you really,
what you realize that you are now into this,
you boiled like,
it's like when you reduce something by heating it up and they basically,
they boiled off all the fucking nerds,
all the people that applied themselves.
And what you were left with was this high concentration of class clowns and
absolute psychos.
And it was the,
I mean it was the best fucking,
there was like going to a goddamn comedy camp and where I went to summer school,
it was like three towns.
So you met these class clowns from three different towns and everybody kind of
had their own fucking style and you had to up your game.
I know I've told these stories before I,
they would,
just that time the guy poured the coke out on the guy mowing the lawn during the
break and we all ran and we sat down and then I fucking teacher came in who was
wearing Bermuda shorts.
I swear to God and I think they were pink.
He starts to lessen and all of a sudden the guy was mowing the lawn comes in,
he's got,
he had on a white tee shirt and the coke had made brown stains all over the
front of it.
It just comes barging in and the fucking Bermuda short teach looks at like,
what the fuck?
He goes,
hang on a second.
And he walks all the way to the back of the class and he sticks his fucking,
he had a square and rectangle head all at the same time like a Fred Flintstone
had.
He sticks it sideways through,
you know,
those school windows and then looks down,
he sees the puddle of coke right underneath the window and he's like,
yeah,
this is yet which one of,
you'll throw the coke out at me and we're all just laughing,
laughing our ass off.
And then,
uh,
you know,
the kid who did it admits that he doesn't give a fuck.
He's not afraid of the principal,
you know,
he's on a first name basis with the guy and it was just like,
it was a great time.
Other than losing your summer,
you know,
Blues Kitten,
hope,
you know,
I'm a red head.
What was going to be out there sunbathing.
Um,
all right,
continuing on.
All right.
Uh,
this is somebody talking about last week,
daughter or gay son.
Whore question from last week.
Uh,
dear Billy,
friend of gay,
I'm a gay male and Alyssa and a listener,
most of the issues that come up in everyday life pertained to the gay community
are overblown.
I came out in the early nineties.
I was a bit more emotional and defensive about things back then because the
climate was very aggressive towards gays.
Um,
the truth is we only have a re we have come a really,
really long way.
It doesn't mean that the prejudice has gone,
but it's a place where there what,
where,
uh,
where the general consumer consciousness of the country is in a much healthier
place.
Um,
last week,
uh,
Rita ass,
who a,
which you'd have a whore of a daughter or a gay son.
Uh,
let me start off by saying that I love Nia and I can see why you do as well.
Sometimes I think she is a bit hard on the listeners and quick to label labeled
them as cave men.
Um,
I gotta tell you this for you and everybody else who thinks she's too harsh and
you guys just know this.
She's not talking to you guys.
All right.
She's talking to me
because she knows how I am and she knows what the fuck I say is,
you got to understand she lives with me.
So when I shut the mic off or whatever,
when I come home from a comedy club,
she is the shit that I say.
And I'm just like,
you guys,
I say all kinds of Shit than I've actually had a real job.
I,
you know,
I'd have to issue some sort of fucking apology,
you know what I mean?
Cause I'm a human being and I'm a moron.
So what she does is she thinks she knows all the shit that I say.
Um,
most of which ends up ends up going to the stage.
I usually end up taking to the stage because she gets so mad at me.
And,
uh,
I,
oh,
you know,
you know what one of them was,
this is actually a great story.
Sorry guys.
I'm fucking in this high altitude and I just worked out and uh,
keep getting fucking dry mouth here.
I know.
It's disgusting.
The listen to me drink here.
I'm sorry.
Um,
all right.
He's a classic one.
That bit I did about Rihanna,
um,
about saying,
you know,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not condoning what the guy did and Bob above blah blah.
But like,
you know,
I was basically speculating what happened,
you know what happened in the car before that shit went down.
I can't remember how the fucking pit went.
So I'm sitting there and I say that shit.
And she just goes,
don't even fucking say it.
Doni cause of right when the story came out,
don't even,
she was doing that shit.
You know when somebody is so mad at you,
they can't even look at you.
She was putting her index finger up,
like going like,
hang on a second.
And she was just sort of looking up with their eyes closed.
Don't even say it,
don't even fucking say,
and I just start laughing and I of course,
yeah,
you tell a comedian,
don't say it.
You know they're going to fucking say it.
It's like that Mr Saturday nights seen Billy crystal when he does that,
what's with the fucking hair when they said don't say it and then you got to say
it.
So,
uh,
so I said,
whatever the fuck I said,
and then she got so mad at me or whatever.
Then we had a giant debate about a surprise.
Surprise.
And then like a week later,
completely unprovoked,
my mother-in-law was over and that story came up again.
And she goes,
you know,
that's terrible,
but I got to admit,
I wonder what she said.
And I start laughing at me.
It's just like mom and I felt totally justified and whatever that ended up being
in that bid or whatever.
So getting back to what you're saying,
she's not,
she's not calling the listeners cavemen.
It's,
and I'll don't,
I labeled them as cavemen.
She's,
she's really talking to me because she thinks I'm a moron.
And then she thinks on the podcasts that I am a Pied Piper for moron.
She doesn't understand that the amount of people that listen to this,
just to listen to how dumb I am and laugh and feel better about themselves or
maybe get fat shamed.
Anyways,
back to the,
uh,
the,
question the here,
um,
he said,
however,
uh,
it is her opinion and I've never thought her wrong for it.
I'm just guys being very diplomatic.
Um,
in this case though,
she was way off the mark.
There was nothing discriminatory about the question.
In fact,
it was the exact opposite.
It was,
um,
and I wish she was here for this.
Um,
it was an inclusive,
it was inclusive and represented the types of thoughts a man having a son could
have raising alarm the way she did.
Sensationalizes some issues that don't even exist.
We do not have chronic problems of wondering which sex we'd rather have be a
whore.
The fact that the question was intended to be humorous,
humorous,
which she did acknowledge,
put it in a category of even less offensiveness.
Uh,
you ever have made many jokes about a million things and implying this is off
limits.
Victimizes the sexual habits of either sex,
uh,
her intent was righteous.
Uh,
but it,
it's this irresponsible,
alarming of any issue that makes it harder for a gay boy to be thought of
equally and also makes it harder for a straight person to become comfortable
with the issues pertaining to sexual,
uh,
orientation.
Ps,
you look better with the
beard.
Oh Shit.
You know,
right.
As I was about ready to say that this was my probably the most dramatically like
best written thing on the podcast.
You could a row,
you get a read that on fucking meet the press.
You got it?
Yeah,
that was perfect.
You set me up with anything yet.
You took a nice fucking uppercut.
Um,
I like having a beard.
I was like being clean shaven,
so you know,
I'm sorry.
You're just going to have to keep looking at that poster of me above your bed,
sir.
Okay.
Because I'm,
I'm going clean shaven here for awhile.
All right.
Yeah,
that clean shaven.
All right.
Fat Shaming.
I already read that one.
Um,
what are we up to here?
Oh,
we're up to one hour.
Um,
graffiti,
a Billy copper crotch.
Do you look at it?
Just take it fucking rights and lefts here.
Is this any way to treat your host?
You know,
I invite you over for free.
I help you with your commute.
Now you do fucking trash in my pubes over there.
Um,
first off,
I like to say I'm a huge fan of the podcast.
Oh,
I know how this goes.
Yeah.
Butter me up.
So then I put my guard down and then you fucking trash my fucking,
I don't know what my giant forehead said.
Always hilarious.
Even so,
even insightful at times.
Oh,
look at that.
Even dummies,
right?
Every once in a while,
a guest we throw the long commute to college every day.
He said,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
his kids,
18 years old.
Oh,
it's even insightful.
You little cunt.
Um,
he said,
I'm an 18 year old from Providence,
Rhode Island.
I've drank there.
I've been into art at ever since I can remember.
I love all forms of it except those dms s sculptures that look like some moron
welded a couple of scraps of junkyard metal together in a pathetic attempt at
being a creative.
Uh,
but the one form of visual expression that has always been my hat and personal
passion is graffiti.
Uh,
uh,
man,
the question got cut off.
Wait a second.
I got it right here.
Hold on.
As a graffiti writer,
I am very aware that many people despise what we do.
Consider it pointless,
ugly,
detrimental to society as well as childish.
Yet I have been utterly curious to know what your opinion slash position of our
art form is.
Be it negative or positive.
I'd be ecstatic to hear you discuss it on the podcast for a bit.
For a bit.
Best wishes to the lovely Nia and you,
you old conch.
Go Fuck you
dude.
Everybody's trying to steal around this week.
You know,
I feel like I'm winning then all of a sudden you fucking sugar ray Leonard,
me here.
Um,
the Psu should come perform somewhere in Rhode Island,
Connecticut or Boston as soon.
And my older brother had been dying to see some authentic Billy boys stand up,
but we lack the finances to travel relatively far from home.
Well,
I'll,
I'll be there definitely.
Uh,
as I build up my next hour,
I haven't been to Boston and uh,
I think it was February of last year,
so I'm dope.
I'm definitely doe.
Um,
okay.
All right,
so what am I,
what is my opinion on it?
I definitely think it's an art form.
I definitely like any art form.
There's some I like more than others.
What I,
my only complaint is the canvas that you guys use.
And I respect the ability to,
uh,
I mean some of some of the,
like someone who actually makes like a painting or something like that is
incredible.
Just sitting there tagging and write in your name.
Then it comes down to how visually I guess stimulating it is.
But my thing is to,
uh,
what kills a lot of it is if you actually spray paint on something that I was
already appreciating and the fact that I know that somebody else owns it and
that you just spray painted all over it.
And I understand that a lot of that art is this outlaw thing.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
those metal things that they pulled down over the doors,
those ugly to look at.
So when graffiti artists spray painted them,
I thought that those look better.
However,
you know,
if you come up like where I live,
there's these guys,
you know,
I don't know this fucking Armenian gang and they tagged shit all the fucking
time and it's stinks.
It's just black spray paint and they just spray their fucking thing.
It's really dumb.
They write danger in one of the things,
which is really stupid.
And I,
and I've told you before that I think Armenians and Russians are the pit bulls
of a,
of humor.
Like I would not eat,
I would not fuck with either one of them on any goddamn level.
However,
I will sit there and the safety of this hotel room in the middle of the Utah
surrounded by Mormons and say that,
that,
that's kind of fucking lame to write danger.
It's just stupid down baiting them to do something dangerous.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I dunno.
I,
I would say it,
it,
I've seen documentaries on,
uh,
you know,
graffiti artists and I definitely have an appreciation for it,
but I,
I'm happy that they're off the subway trains in New York.
MMM.
I always hated that shit.
Then they started scratching up the seats and shit.
And it's just like,
isn't it awful enough that these things are going to be filthy because so many
people are in here that you have to fucking ruin it now by scratching up the
windows and all this type of shit.
And like,
I don't,
you know,
all that bullshit that they say,
well,
you know,
okay.
I guess with some inner city kids,
they have this,
you know,
they feel invisible and this is their way of the,
of,
of what fucking ruining property.
I don't,
that's,
I don't know,
there's gotta be a better way to do it,
but I have to tell you out in la,
there's some amazing,
amazing stuff that I have seen.
So,
uh,
I dunno.
So I,
yeah,
I do appreciate
it,
but sometimes,
you know,
it's just some of the shit,
like they got a lot of stuff.
Uh,
you know,
La is just classic for just Taren,
some beautiful old building down and then just sticking up a fucking strip mall
and there's not a lot of stuff like that left.
So when there is something like that,
some art deco look and stuff and some kid comes up and spray paints all over it.
Um,
you know,
I don't like that.
I think I then,
I think it's ugly.
I think,
uh,
you there was already a piece of art and then you fucking like,
in a way it's like you're cock block and you're not enhancing it or whatever.
Um,
I would say that,
you know,
it is funny though,
is when you see somebody driving down the street and like some truck and it's
just fucking graffiti all over it.
That always makes me laugh because I always think about,
uh,
the Griswold family truckster when they pulled in and they went to ask for
directions,
which was absolutely hilarious.
You couldn't do a scene like that now because it would probably be considered
too racist or whatever.
But it was fucking hilarious.
They pull in in this steel,
in their hubcaps and all that type of Shit and spray painted.
It was basically,
it was a def jam bit like what's his face?
Chevy chase was the white guy,
you know,
hey,
how are ya?
Just trying to get back out on the highway,
you know,
that type of shit.
So,
oh,
you know what,
I forgot to bring up his,
something else I wanted to show you guys before,
uh,
before I get out of here,
um,
is I got a new rear end put in on my truck.
I finally just,
I,
you know,
I went out to Texas when I hung out with those guys over at gas monkey.
They were telling me,
cause I got still at that granny transmission in there and I wanted to keep it,
you know,
a three speed on the column.
I just think it's cool as hell to be shifted on the column.
And um,
so I didn't want,
I,
you know,
I didn't want to fuck with the linkage or something like that where all of a
sudden I don't,
I don't,
I don't actually,
to be honest with you,
I don't know if I put a fourth gear,
if that means now I got to have it on the floor.
Just always seem as four on the floor,
three on the tree.
So I'm one of the guys over there at gas.
Margaret says,
yeah,
just throw new rear ended,
you know,
that cause my truck basically red lines at about it was about 50,
55 doesn't red line,
but it's making enough noise with the engine's working too hard because it's
basically designed to just kind of haul shit around on a farm.
Um,
so whatever.
So I put a new rear ended.
I didn't put it anywhere.
Uh,
obviously,
uh,
I had some other guys do it and uh,
it's fucking amazing.
It's fucking amazing.
And now it's making me,
now it can cruise at like 65,
which is night and day.
You know,
55 to 65,
65 you're cruising at 55,
you're actually going to cause an accident.
You bump up that extra 10 miles.
It's huge.
And now,
um,
I dunno,
I think I kinda got the bug.
I really want to keep the truck as original as I can,
but
to the point that I've,
everything that I've changed on the truck,
I've kept the original,
like when I had an aluminum radiator put in,
I kept the original want to have that in my garage when not Christopher Titus
helped me do the,
the front brakes basically showed me what to do.
I kept the uh,
the drums and the shoes and all that shit.
I have that and now I have back there,
I have my opinion and ring gear from the rear end and um,
I found this great website,
I got to find it.
That actually explains gear ratios and how to do them.
You got to check it out.
It's one of the coolest like fucking,
yeah,
it's one of the coolest things sites I ever read as far as like mechanics go and
you really understand like racing a lot better.
Like the push pull of ad,
it gets all about weight,
you know,
trying to get the car to go as fast as it can while still keep keeping it as
light as possible.
It's fucking amazing.
That whole balance.
Um,
and just all the shit that they do to the car.
It just makes it,
I feel like I moved up three levels in my limited understanding of,
it's really,
really fucking fascinating stuff.
And,
uh,
I already forget how to do gear ratios,
but I counted the rings on my old,
uh,
ring gear and,
and on the pinion and I was able to figure out what kind of rear end that I had
and I was trying to get over to the garage when they were putting the new one in
because they were going to actually,
you know,
show me how to like the way tidy,
show me.
We're going to show me some shit,
but,
and of course ended up getting some crap that I had to do so I wasn't able to do
it.
But,
um,
so that'll be it.
I'll show you the rock climbing thing.
I'll show you the guy showing you how to do a muscle up and I'll show you
what else,
what I just talked about,
the gear ratios.
Oh.
And then the last thing too,
just to keep it fair,
so it's not all testosterone stuff.
I'm going to show you a a fucking cake youtube clip that I saw today on how to
basic,
it's pretty basic how to just make an egg within some bread.
You know,
like an egg over easy.
And this woman actually makes it with a little heart shape.
So you can do a teeth for your wife.
I'm telling you,
this is a type of shit you do that you know.
So then when you actually fuck up,
they have that enter their head.
Oh well he made me an egg in the heart shape thing.
So I watched this thing showing you how to do it.
It's really basic,
which is why I couldn't understand it,
but I have to,
I got to show you this thing.
I don't want an,
I don't want it.
Like I don't want to bait you guys into writing a bunch of mean comments.
All right?
There's something in the video that is super fucking annoying that you're not
supposed to make fun of.
So I won't.
All right,
but I'm just letting you know that,
you know,
there's cute and then there's fucking annoying and I felt that this video went
into annoying,
but other than that,
I'll put that up there anyways.
All right.
But keep your comments fucking Nice,
you guys.
You guys say way too much mean ship a lot of you too.
You guys go way over the top.
You know,
if you don't like my wife's been on that I get it.
Can just say that you don't have to go as far as your fucking go.
So really a,
you know,
I mean,
that's fucked up.
Me saying that considering I trash everything,
but uh,
you know,
just fuck it.
Dial it back a little bit.
All right.
You can.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week of fuck yourself.
I'm telling you right now,
United States,
I'm praying they make the World Cup final.
I'm praying that they went in and I'm praying that 40 people show up.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.